I know one thing that you love that I'm
gonna put on that sandwich and you're
gonna love it I know it is gonna be come
on Oh in it it's just the one thing that
asked for it every restaurant yep um
ranch I would say our relationship is
about 80 percent or 85 consist of just
eating he has a lot of allergies which
is weird
cuz he's a big man and he's gonna be
taken down by a cranberry one day I have
a feeling I know his food preferences
better than he knows mine I'm probably
never gonna send you out to grab dinner
again if you get it wrong that's I've
never been this nervous in my life if I
can find a soul mate today
that'd be pre sweet hello hi I'm Carol
I'm Chris nice to meet you we have not
gone on a date before no cats versus
dogs this is very important a I hang out
with friends you have friends I have
friends that's a good side I need people
like you do you like animals
I love wait a lot yes this is a blank
question especially if I'm gonna end up
me okay men yes I really like it
don't screw it up
now that it's like the moment of truth
and the app is like right here in front
of me not kind of nervous okay let's
begin so I'm gonna do a foot long cuz
Garrett's six seven she really really
really loves animals so I'm gonna go
with a veggie Delite tomatoes for sure
just better not at any jalapeno peppers
I'm gonna throw some bacon on there
think you like Chipotle Southwest sauce
I'm not tilt the sauce is the thing that
makes me the most nervous I think I
always hit the sweet onion sauce and
she's not she's not gonna pick the sweet
onion sauce all the ranch dressing you
bad ranch on there I put ranch on
everything tuna spinach tomatoes
cucumbers cucumbers green peppers olives
red onions the more I look at it the
less confident I am so I feel like I
just need to put the order and just go I
think Garrett cheated yeah you cheated
what yours is easy it's just vegetables
you're right on the size oh yeah thank
you
I'm a just little like you made yours
big look it's asked if we were
sandwiches so pretty uh jalapeno I told
you I love olive it use all the
vegetables basically except for tomatoes
I went with vinaigrette yeah ranch
dressing that's the most important one
pickles no pickle I'm seeing spinach
tomato pepper black olives very good I
think he knows me better than I thought
he did you did not disappoint you'd not
ruin this date he already half the
sandwich why did I happen